[Music]
have you ever wondered what happens to a
painkiller like ibuprofen after you
swallow it medicine that slides down
your throat can help treat a headache a
sore back or a throbbing sprained ankle
but how does it get where it needs to go
in the first place the answer is that it
hitches a ride in your circulatory blood
stream cycling through your body in a
race to do its job before it's snared by
organs and molecules designed to
neutralize and expel foreign substances
this process starts in your digestive
system say you swallow an ibuprofen
tablet for a sore ankle within minutes
the tablet starts disintegrating in the
acidic fluids of your stomach the
dissolved ibuprofen travels into the
small intestine and then across the
intestinal wall into a network of blood
vessels these blood vessels feed into a
vein which carries the blood and
anything in it to the liver the next
step is to make it through the liver as
the blood and the drug molecules in it
travel through liver blood vessels
enzymes attempt to react with the
ibuprofen molecules to neutralize them
the damaged ibuprofen molecules called
metabolites may no longer be effective
as painkillers at this stage most of the
ibuprofen makes it through the liver
unscathed it continues its journey out
of the liver through veins into the
body's circulatory system half an hour
after you've swallowed the pill some of
the dose has already made it into the
circulatory bloodstream this blood loop
travels through every lemon organ
including the heart brain kidneys and
back through the liver
when ibuprofen molecules encounter a
location where the body's pain response
is in full-swing
they bind to specific target molecules
that are part of that reaction
painkillers like ibuprofen block the
production of compounds that help the
body transmit pain signals as more drug
molecules accumulate the pain canceling
effect increases reaching a maximum
within about one or two hours then the
body starts efficiently eliminating
ibuprofen with the blood dose decreasing
by half every two hours on average
when the ibuprofen molecules detached
from their targets the systemic
bloodstream carries them away again back
in the liver
another small fraction of the total
amount of the drug gets transformed into
metabolites which are eventually
filtered out by the kidneys in the urine
the loot from liver to body to kidneys
continues at a rate of about one blood
cycle per minute with a little more of
the drug neutralized and filtered out in
each cycle these basic steps are the
same for any drug that you take orally
but the speed of the process and the
amount of medicine that makes it into
your bloodstream varies based on drug
person and how it gets into the body the
dosing instructions on medicine labels
can help but their averages based on a
sample population that doesn't represent
every consumer and getting the dose
right is important if it's too low the
medicine won't do its job if it's too
high the drug and its metabolites can be
toxic that's true of any drug one of the
hardest groups of patients to get the
right dosage for our children
that's because how they process medicine
changes quickly as do their bodies for
instance the level of liver enzymes that
neutralize medication highly fluctuates
during infancy and childhood and that's
just one of many complicating factors
genetics age diet disease and even
pregnancy influence the body's
efficiency of processing medicine some
day routine DNA tests may be able to
dial in the precise dose of medicine
personalized to your liver efficiency
and other factors but in the mean time
your best bet is reading the label or
consulting your doctor or pharmacist and
taking the recommended amounts with the
recommended timing
[Music]